hello you sexy people out there this is
Tim Ferriss and this episode of the Tim
Ferriss podcast has a very special guest
Josh Waitzkin whom I met in 2007 after
reading his spectacular book the art of
learning Josh you may know from
searching for bobby fisher' he was the
subject of both the book and the movie
he's thought of as a chess prodigy
although that term prodigy I don't
believe applies to him well at all
because he has a method for learning
mastering refining any skill whether
that is chess whether that is Taichi in
which he is multiple time world champion
Brazilian jiu-jitsu in which he's a
black belt under the the Phenom the
Michael Jordan of the sport marcelo
garcia and he's worked with people
ranging from mark messier six-time
Stanley Cup winner to Cal Ripken jr. to
the top hedge fund managers in the world
he is a performance specialist and also
a very dear friend of mine now at this
point and I ended up loving his book the
art of learning so much that I acquired
the rights to his audio book if you want
to find that it's read by Josh himself
and you can just go to for our blog fyu
Rho u RB l OG comm and search for Tim
Ferriss book club or go to Google and do
the same so without further ado let's
get straight to the meat of the
interview I hope you enjoy it
optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I also the personal
question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton ferrous so so
Josh I figure you might as well start at
the top and do a little retrospective
what led you initially to write the art
of learning of course that's how I was
in many ways introduced to your work and
then through our mutual friend max ended
up connecting but what was the what was
the reason you decided to write that
book yeah you know I initially started
thinking about about the idea of the
book about two years into my martial
arts less so I transitioned from chance
into studying into meditating into
studying East Asian philosophy then I
started getting into Tai Chi Chuan and
ultimately into the martial application
of it push ends and I started to
experience this very interesting
transition from from the principles my
level in chess just began to translate
directly over into the martial arts and
I say I think it was primarily one
experience I had it was something around
two years into my tragic training I was
giving the simultaneous chess exhibition
in Memphis Tennessee at a fundraiser for
muscular dystrophy and I was playing 45
or 50 boards at once I was walking down
the middle of this big square of chess
tables everyone's playing one game I'm
playing each of them and about 40
minutes into the Simon I had this
experience that was so interesting I
began to feel like I was riding the
energetic wave of the game like I was in
my push hands training I wasn't playing
chess I wasn't thinking in chest
language I was in calculating variations
I was feeling the flow filling the space
behind like I would in the martial arts
and I had this realization you know I
was playing beautiful chess but I wasn't
consciously playing chess but the
barriers between these two different are
to dissolve in my mind and that's when I
started to conceive of the idea of the
book and a lot of the process of I spent
five years taking notes me for 500 pages
of notes in the book before I actually
sat down and wrote it and a lot of that
process was deconstructing what I've
been doing rather intuitively
so essentially what it felt like with
all those translation of within parallel
learning these are two
abstract terms that's the language that
I was using internally when I was first
thing about the book because if I was
taking the essence of one art and
translating it over into another and the
process of writing it involved
deconstructing what I've been doing um
somewhat abstract Li into something that
could be replicated more systematically
so he the question that jumps out in my
mind which is a bit of a side note
perhaps but is Simon's playing you 10 20
30 40 boards simultaneously I
I'll try to ask a better question than
how does someone do that but at what
point what happens to a chess player
when they go from an inability to play
multiple board simultaneously to being
able to play multiple board
simultaneously what is the sort of
framework or thinking or X or experience
and someone builds up that allows them
to do something like that which to the
average person seems like a Rain Man
like feet you know I think it's
different for every chess player I mean
one of the beautiful things about chess
is that you can approach in so many
different ways and to be world-class
what you need to do essentially is
Express the core of your being through
the art I think that's just true of many
arts and that's probably said that will
give in to more deeply so you can have a
very mathematical person who plays chess
mathematically you can have a very
musical person who plays chess music
someone might be much more kinesthetic
like myself and it's sort of a feeling
for flow and hidden harmonies and and
almost a physically energetic
relationship to chess
um when I first learned to play chess
when I was six years old in Washington
Square Park it was a battle I love the
feeling of just going to into a fight
with someone and finding these hidden
harmonies and finding where these animal
passions mixed with this technical
complexity and when I get late much
later when I got much better playing
Simoes um it was sort of a higher level
manifestation of that same kind of
dynamic I mean for me playing Simoes was
it something akin to juggling a lot of
balls and and all of the to each chest I
wasn't playing 40 different games for
example separately the flow of all 40
games would sort of coalesce into one
larger sense of flow and it was actually
really interesting
whenever often would I give a sigh
Milland there'd be a youth competition
and the winners of the competition would
play against me and so sometimes kids
would would cheats they'd really want to
be nice to they were cheats off you're
walking around this big thing and then I
get to the table made a mood shift to
the positions try to win cuz they win it
would be a big thing and my experience
when that happened was as if you had
imagine you're like 40 balls up in the
air and suddenly they're all crashed
onto the floor yeah and I I would know
that they would change the position not
by reaching the board and remembering
what the position was and then seeing
they changed it it would initially be
this feeling of the energetic flow had
been interrupted and then I have to
reverse engineer myself back to that one
what one game that one component of the
flow and then I'd remember the game and
then I would remember exactly she had
been and I'd say aha this is the
position and then it'll take me two or
three times going back around to get
that all the balls back up in here to
get back to the energetic flow so
actually for me giving Simon's sort of
felt similar playing chest one chess
game but that was my own relationship to
it I think that probably if you had ten
different very strong chess players that
all give someone different answers got
it yeah this you know what they that
blew me away was a spending time with a
friend of yours Maurice and when we went
to Washington Square Park and seeing him
play a game uh-huh
at least for the first portion without
looking at the board and I'm not gonna I
won't give away too much of the too much
of the the punch line since we we
captured it all on a film it was pretty
amazing but this his ability to track
the board I it seemed like by chunking
portions of the board into sort of
larger like Gestalt pieces I don't know
if that's the best way to express it but
it seemed like his ability to seemingly
remember all these disparate pieces was
because he had it broken
the board broken down into sort of
component chunks as it were but I don't
to take us to down that that fine line
let's let's shift gears I wonder what
I'd be very curious to know is you know
at this point what what because I know
of course a little bit of the background
but I want to dig into the details what
what type of
people do you personally work with these
days and why do they work with you what
type of things do you do with them
yeah well I have three major dimensions
to my my creative life right now what
maybe four if I guess the most important
one is my son Jack who I used a little
over two years old and love in my life
so that's maybe the most important part
of my life no question about it I run a
non-profit Educational Foundation and we
have I'll call the JW foundation the art
of learning projects and we have a
couple hundred programs and schools
around the country internationally as
well and so this is integrating these
principles that have been developing in
schools working with teachers parents
and children around this individualized
thematic relationship to learning that
I've been developing so this is one
dimension the other one is I own a
martial art school a Brazilian jiu-jitsu
school with um
Marcel Garcia who's the nine-time world
champion you know I'm well Tim he just
made really the Michael Jordan of the
grappling world um scissors broke as a
fleet straining there and then I run a
consulting business where I'm training
people who are at the cutting edge of
the finance world and this is really
interesting work as we're focusing on
that last one or 0.1 percent of the
learning process which is really my
specialty it's it's highly
individualized as cutting edge work on
their learning process their idea
generation their creativity their
performance ecology their resilience arm
fascinating work and you know what I've
discovered it's interesting because I I
wrote this book called the art of
learning years ago and so people are
always coming to me to speak about
learning but much of what I've been
focused on in recent years has been
unlearning when I think when I think
about that loss that last movement you
know from the equivalent of being say
number 10 to number one in the world
number five to being number one in the
world it's much more about finding
subtle obstructions finding friction
points releasing them identifying
cognitive biases and blocking your way
it's sort of it's the movement towards
unobstructed self expressions ever you
think about about your creative process
as a hose with with a big crimp in it if
you release it just unbelievable
pressure can be released and a lot of
what I'm doing with people is trying to
move them from from very good to greater
from great to truly elite
um I just deeply individualized work on
helping them really find ways to express
the core of their being through their
art which is as you know a big theme in
my life from when I played chess at my
high level that's what I was doing when
I had a period of being really locked up
in my chairs career which we can go into
in more detail if you want I was doing
the opposite I was trying to fit into
someone else's mold and then ultimately
when I transitioned away from chess into
the martial arts I returned to that
experience of self-expression and that's
what I really start to understand it
very deeply I think it was the crisis
towards the end of my chest career which
really lower the foundation for the work
that I do today with with brilliant
mental performers who were just trying
to make that movement to be equivalent
to world champion to to jump actually
back to Marcelo for a second because
I've I've worse met Marcelo and he's
just and you've gone to war with him and
I've watched you I've gone to war with
him which I if there's anything at stake
I don't recommend and the guys got me a
lot of pain over the years he's a tough
guy but also a sweetheart of the guy and
I he's so fluid what I'd love to hear
from you of course because in the in the
art of learning which which some people
might be familiar with they read about
your experiences in chess your
experiences in Tai Chi the parallels
between them and this sort of over
arching you know framework for
optimizing mental and physical
performance if that's a fair way to put
it which is the art of learning with
these different techniques and
strategies what what have you learned
through this third art or Brazilian
Jujitsu what are what are some insights
or strategies that you've had since
moving from Tai Chi which is in some
ways similar but also very different
from Brazilian Jujitsu which a lot of
people would be familiar with through
the UFC and mixed martial arts right all
right yeah I mean to put it in context
wrote it to my left so the bit of
learning ends with the 2004 World
Championship it ends with describing the
narrative of that it was just absolutely
higher on crazy
experience um I won't give the punchline
but but it was really intense and and
after this I started I decided I want to
be a beginner again to put on a white
belt um literally and figuratively and
so I took on this third major mountain
in my life pursue I was training out in
the West Coast for about a year when I
was actually writing the art of learning
I was training Brazilian jiu-jitsu twice
twice a day
um this is after I'd spent five years
taking notes then I had a 2004 world's
when I was writing it I saw training
with John Machado out there then I came
back to New York I started training with
Marco Santos here and I started develop
this relationship with Marcelo who is
just the greatest grappler to ever live
and we were doing private lessons I was
we developed a friendship um then he
moved to Florida and I would travel to
Florida to work with him and ultimately
I made the decision I wanted to bring
him to New York mostly because I I was
at that point planning to make a run for
the World Championship in this art and
there was no better way to do it then to
get my ass kicked by the very best to
ever live in the sport and he's just a
wonderful guy
and he's just unbelievable martial
artists and so we opened up the school
together and and I've been on the mats
with him you know other than when we one
of us has been injured and it's been a
lot of injuries in these sports just all
the time and it's been a fascinating
experience anymore so it was so
profoundly different from me I'm a
really conceptual guy I think abstractly
of course my foundation in sheds more
Marcelo is one of the most well he's the
most kin as medically over developed
person we've ever met and of course over
development under development tend to
come hand at hand conceptually um to
give me an example of that would be an
example of over development or
development of kinesthetic what it means
to be kinesthetically
his physical intelligence is
mind-boggling I mean when he come
fishing with me at you know you throw
them on a stand-up paddleboard um in
three foot shop and everyone just flies
off of paddle boards and they just stand
up on them and he's just beautiful and
you just find the balance points and
I've ever seen one soon someone learned
so quickly how to handle um
waves boats handling fishing lines being
you know free diving being on riding
waves on paddle boards
you know we use when you're the more
stand-up fighter for many years and
throwing as Mike or Mike or art when I'm
doing stand-up train with more so I
caught him with most of the throws in my
repertoire one time I don't think I've
ever caught him with a throw twice
Wow many a night as world-class oh I was
training with you I catch them thousands
of times this is a guy he just you
almost never see Marcelo get caught more
than once with something um and it's
amazing to see how he relates the world
through his kinesthetic intelligence so
for example if you're looking when we
were looking for spaces for our school
we'd walk into a big room and I'd be
thinking about the dimensions you know
square footage where this would be where
that would be Marcela would know if it
felt good or felt bad yeah if he meets
you he's gonna know whether he feels
good about you or he feels bad about you
and his intuition is incredibly dead-on
but he navigates the world through this
kinesthetic intelligence yeah and it's
been a really fascinating having the
school with him and diving deep with him
um because we've been having conceptual
dialogue though these three and a half
years or so and he's really deep in
conceptually um but I've learned even
more deeply the importance of the lesson
that there are many paths to greatness
and to take a guy like Marcelo to try to
fit him into chess players you know
hyper conceptual mold would be terrible
killing his shine and he is so great
because of his just unbelievable
commitment to doing it his way he's done
things in extraordinary ways I mean for
example you know how these competitive
arts everyone's very secretive about the
repertory yeah um we have this program
which you know well called ng action
where people Jitsu guys around the world
log in to watch all of ourselves
training sessions his sparring sessions
is less of everything when he was
competing in Abu Dhabi submission
grappling World Championship and when
gels which is the Brazilian Jujitsu
World Championship
we were spurt we were streaming his
sparring sessions every night so he was
basically showing his competitors what
he was about to use against them Suites
in three weeks and four weeks and his
attitude about this which is completely
unique is if you're studying my game
you're entering my game and I'll be
better at than you
simple secure and if you think about it
really yeah arm the opposite of what
most chess players would do and most you
just got to do and so he's wide open to
constant learning the other beautiful
thing about Marcelo is you know if
people call him the king of scrambles
and if you watch his training style he's
always in transition which is a really
interesting idea to think about in a
cross-disciplinary matter because most
people get their egos involved in their
training they're trying to dominate all
the time and to dominate and almost
anything you find a position of
dominance and you keep it Marcelo always
led to the pawns move and so he's
constantly playing in transition and so
if you think about what world-class
martial arts means and you brought up
for example Maurice Ashley and it saying
chess and Washington Square it's similar
if you're at a much higher level than
someone you can always seem mystical
because you're doing things which are
outside of their conceptual scheme the
way that operates in the martial arts is
if you think about it to the lens of
frames right if you and I are looking at
a position and in your mind there's
disposition leads to this position to
this position so there's three positions
in my mind if I'm constantly training at
the transitions between these positions
these actually expand in these
transitional frames become positions to
me and so if I'm seeing a hundred
positions when you're seeing take two
that I can play in your blind spots and
it can seem mystical to you because you
haven't trained there and that's what
Marcelo does by expending all of his
time in transition he's cultivated the
art to play in the in-between which is
really what level is all about one of
the core things that highlight the
world-class martial arts is all about
playing in transition in gaps that you
know in your opponent's side pattern
oh no I mean observing and practicing
with marcelo say on the guillotine to
the marcelo team just blew me away
because if you look at it as an
uninformed spectator or even just a
moderately informed spectator you're
blown away by how fast it is how
effectively he is but the the nuance of
sort of eliciting movement allowing
space to open manufacturing space by
let's say applying pressure and then
leaving it is so subtle and so
incredibly effective I mean then you
start to notice it from these these
principles that carry over to many many
hundreds of possible positions let's
just say it's really yeah it's really
amazing I mean it well then what reminds
me of something I heard once from a
musician which was I don't know who the
original quote is from but he said that
you know music is the space between the
notes and I was like huh that's a really
interesting way to look at it but but
but what were you going to say I was
going to say I think that's just a
gorgeous quote I think that's most great
arts are defined by that that's based in
between yeah well it's like writing
writing is the same way right it's like
you know when in doubt leave it out it's
just like you know it's uh I think yeah
beautiful beautiful plan and of course
the thing about Marcelo is that it can
often seem initially that he's moving so
fast but what's incredible that he can
also move very slow and do things that
you don't see I'm just like a great side
up side of hand artists who's just
practicing the art of Illusion when
we're not practicing it's amazing what
can be done with intention with
controlling someone's intention and this
is with a lot of my training and push
hands related to finding ways to to
essentially control someone's intention
so that you were ahead of them even if
if they were ultimately moving first you
were there before they arrived there's a
fascinating psychological component of
really high level training in anything
well I I remember an interview or wasn't
an interview a well no wasn't interview
actually with one of the top k1 fighters
back in the day and they were talking
about Peter Aerts enter if you remember
the Dutch lumberjack huge guy and he all
he seemed fast and I remember what
people said a number of opponents said
you know he's he's actually not that
fast he's kind of a big lumbering guy
but he's so good at predicting timing
that he sees you Telegraph before you
even have the thought to throw the punch
and he beats you to the punch as a
result of that but it's because he picks
up on the cues faster than
other people I thought that was very
interesting to to try to bridge this to
something else I mean what you work with
of course I'm not gonna mention names
but you work with some of the most
stunningly successful and famous traders
and people in finance I mean some real
kind of masters of the universe type
folks what what have you what have you
found unique about that group of people
let's let's let's just start with that
I'm curious to know kind of what you've
what you've noticed being as observant
as you are about that group of folks
that's a big question
it is a big question yeah first of all I
I think a core principle start with is
that there are many paths to greatness I
mean each one of these guys who's really
world-class is doing it his way and he's
harnessing that contributing for his or
her strengths as a way of life there's
none excessive focus on weakness there's
just an embracing of a deep deep
studying of the preconditions to
someone's finest moments of expression
and building lifestyle surrounded and
that's a lot of what I do is help people
understand what makes them tick on a
very very deep level relative to you
know the cognitive biases where they
locked up and where the raisins has come
what kind of external conditions what
kind of internal conditions and the ones
who are really at the top are people who
who have mastered this art of deep
introspection and taking the result of
these introspective prophecies and turn
them into training systems and into a
way of life
and it's fascinating how how you know
the process works and what I do with
these guys is I I if after I do my
initial diagnostic process I have ways
of revamping the daily architecture the
way they live their life so that their
for example aligning their peak energy
periods with a key creativity work
they're building lifestyles that are
just relentlessly proactive as opposed
to reacting to inputs they're building a
daily architecture which is based on
maximizing the creative process and if
you think about this
to most people on a simple case in point
is email checking right most people when
they finish a break even even top guys
in industries when they finish a break
whether they wake up first in the
morning what most people do they check
their email um when they come back from
a workout whether they check their email
um when you know they come back from
lunch where do they check their email
and so what you see is this whenever
they're coming back from something after
a break they're soaking in inputs and so
they live this reactive lifestyle there
the creative process is dominated by
external noise as opposed to internal
music and a lot of what I work on with
guys is is creating rhythms in their
life that really are based on feeding
the unconscious mind which is really
which is the wellspring of creativity
information and then tapping it so for
example ending the workday with high
quality focus on a certain or of
complexity where you could use an
insight and then waking up first thing
in the morning pre input and applying
your mind to it journaling on it um not
so much to do it a big brainstorm but to
tap what you've been working on
unconsciously overnight which of course
is a principle that Hemingway wrote
about when he spoke about the two core
principles in his creative writing
process for one ending the workday with
something left to right yep oh and
mid-sentence even right so not doing
everything you had to do which most
people do they feel the sense of guilt
if they're not working you and I have
discussed this at length but leaving
something left to right and then waking
up and then second principle release
your mind from it don't think about it
all night really let go have a glass of
wine then wake up first thing in the
morning and reapply your mind to it and
it's amazing because you're basically
feeding the mind complexity and then tap
in that complexity or tapping what
you've done with it and I mean this
rhythm you know the large variation of
it is overnight then you can do micro
burst of it throughout the day before
workouts pose a question do a workout
release your mind after workout return
to it and you'll create a burst before
you go to the bathroom before you go to
lunch before anything and there's a ways
of systematically training yourself to
generate the crystallization experience
by aha moment that can happen once a
month or once a year a lot of what I do
is work on systems to help it happen
once a day or four times a day arm and
when you're talking about guys who run
finance or groups of twenty to thirty
billion dollars for example if they have
a huge insight that can that can have
unbelievable value so if you can really
train people to get systematic about
nurturing their creative process it's
unbelievable what can happen and most of
that work relates to getting out of your
own way at a very high level it's it's
unlearning it's the constant practice of
your subtraction reducing friction what
would be an example
you've mentioned cognitive biases a few
times for those people who may not be
familiar with that term what would be an
example of cognitive biases and how
someone might work on them right well
there are a lot of cognitive biases that
are that are specific to certain
disciplines like chess or finance or
philosophy um but if we just think about
it in terms of everyday life let's say
we make a decision and we then feel the
need to justify that decision and so we
make more decisions to justify that
initial decision and then we basically
get ourselves into this deep wormhole
which is caused by the attempt to
justify the sub call like sunk cost
fallacy exactly so this is in the
financial in the world of cognitively
sunk cost policy right um but this is
very interesting for for example a chess
player who makes a certain decision and
there's a certain emotional and
intellectual and time component to the
value we put into the thought process
behind that decision and what we often
have to do is release it because the
position changes shape a very
interesting way that is manifested chess
which you can think about rather
universally is let's say that there's a
certain evaluation to the position right
um you and I are playing Tim and I have
a slight advantage in the position I'm
nurturing that advantage of nurturing
I'm nurturing it um in a lot of
complexity I make a slight error and
suddenly the addition is equalized right
so if I'm holding on to the past
evaluation emotionally where I have the
advantage then what I'm going to do very
subtly is I'm going to reject positions
that don't give me that advantage
but if objectively I no longer have an
advantage that I'm going to be reaching
too far right um and then I'm rejecting
the
they should accept which will make my
position split more and more and more
and you fall into what I call a downward
spiral yep so this relates to a lack of
presence which really connects to a
cognitive bias an addiction to a past
evaluation as opposed to a present one
so that's a very simple example of a
cognitive bias a mental addiction a
thought construct something that we hold
to be true because of some complicated
twist in our mind but it's no longer
actually true and so of course a very
simple antidote too much of most of this
is presence if we can look at a moment
or a chess position or an investment
decision or any decision with very clean
presence outside of kind of emotional
inertia um then we can often slice
through just amazing amounts of fat with
just very very simple decisions if you
think about the learning process for
example this is one thing they love
about your approach to learning I
language that you and I uses you know I
call you a master of deconstruction you
look at the way people approach
different sports and you find the biases
be false construct right um and you find
a way to learn to take a very straight
path to learning as opposed to people
getting mired and also too tangled webs
of complexity which which are you know
essentially caused by cognitive biases
wouldn't isn't how you'd put it yeah I
think that's I think that's true and I
obviously appreciate the kind words I
mean I think you and I have very
complimentary approaches and like you've
I think said before it I tend to focus
on the sub 80/20 analysis as it as it
applies to people getting up and off the
ground as quickly as possible to say you
know top whatever five to ten percent
the general population whereas what's so
cool about our conversations would I
enjoy so much in part is that you know
you're really focusing on that that that
final leap how do you go from being
great to being the best right and
they're they're very they're they're
very complementary skill sets I I think
that yeah what I'm looking at and this
is it is a is a way to unearth cognitive
biases and just as a side note for
people who want to look into this you
can just go to Wikipedia and search list
of cognitive biases and there's a
there's a long list which is pretty fun
to read
and there are a number of books about
these types of things to think twice I
think is another one on the the question
that I asked myself and I'm always
interested in the questions that people
ask themselves because I find it in my
to my mind that those that internal
dialogue is what defines your day to day
thinking and what you think you become
so it's so critical that you ask
yourself the right questions and in my
mind what or I should say rather when
I'm trying to deconstruct say a sport
all I'll ask is to start with you know
what what rules are people following
that are not required right so you know
outside of the law and science and even
within science and within law reality is
kind of negotiable so I mean a good
instance of that is the high jump and
the phosphor a flops dick Fosbury it was
really the first guy to go backwards
over the high jump and up to that point
there had been straddle kicks and all
sorts of different approaches and he was
you know ridiculed at first and then he
was called a cheat because they won the
gold medal and now everybody uses that
approach and so you know having a list
of questions right who's good at this
who shouldn't be is another one that I
love to ask because you might find
someone for instance you were talking
about the different styles and in chess
or jiu-jitsu or in chess you know the as
sort of the reference to you your first
book you have attacking chess players
right then you have you have very
different stylistic differences and
you're very quantitative players and you
know for the for the TV show for the Tim
Ferriss experiment I did an episode on
poker and I've avoided poker my whole
life because I viewed it as a game of
chance and I had a former computer
science guy who said no no no I'm not
going to teach you to be lucky because I
can't teach you to be lucky but I can
teach you to run some probabilities and
only bet when you have a good likelihood
of a positive positive outcome right and
what what was so fascinating is you look
at a guy like that and you'll find
highly quantitative say hedge fund
managers for instance or there are
investors of different types
investors who go to the World Series of
Poker and they run the numbers that's
how they play and then there are other
guys who are completely seemingly flying
by the seat of their pants I mean
they're very kinesthetic they're playing
intimidation game they're very physical
and so asking myself for instance and
who's good at this who shouldn't be if
the assumption is you have to be very
good in math to be good at poker right
who admits to using no math which might
be misinformation but and let me look
into how they do it and then the second
question is you have they replicated
their results are there other people
they've taught to do what they do to try
to separate out the the nature from the
nurture where possible but I want to
come back to you know the the finance
guys just for a second and yeah to ask
you about rituals and routines then I'm
going to ask you about your own but what
are some habits and it doesn't have to
be across the board with all these guys
because they have such different
personalities and approaches but with
some of these really super high level
finance guys for managing tens of
billions of dollars what are some of the
habits that you've observed that you
find interesting or rituals all right
let me answer that by describing some of
the may be a the Keystone habits that I
recommend for people to internalize and
in the field versus arm
what will mean first of all meditation I
mean we're speaking about this this
theme of cognitive biases or find it
basically observing your mental dictions
the moment that they said in meditation
is as deep and as powerful a tool as as
I could possibly describe I mean it's
it's in and maybe six or seven years ago
when I was first talking about
meditation with guys in the finance
world it seemed like some whoo-whoo
strange thing for them to take on but as
more more people are integrating into
the process and you wouldn't believe how
many of the most powerful players in the
world are meditating very deeply it's
just an amazing way of deepening
deepening the creative process deepening
presence expanding your energetic
relationships the world's gaining
insight um and realizing that most of
the thinking
that we do basically Springs from mental
addiction and much of people's lives are
spent in an emotional swirl which is a
reactive one and having a relationships
presence which allows you to see through
the kind of illusion of that emotional
swirl or of those mental addictions I
mean meditation is an incredibly
powerful tool as I know you know my
people have been meditating since I was
17 18 years old you know it's a big part
of your life as well Tim so that's a
very very important habit the idea of
waking up first in the morning and
turning your mind the creative work pre
input as opposed to checking email and
getting reactive opening up your channel
to the unconscious mind first thing when
you wake up in the morning doing the
same ending the workday with quality
hugely important I remember when I went
skiing with billy kid who you might
recall that one of them the great
downhill racers from back in I think the
60s limbic ski team awesome dude now he
skis out in Colorado wearing a cowboy
hat
um just timeless guy brilliant dude and
you know he was saying to me years ago
when I first skied with him Josh what do
you think of the three most important
turns of the ski run and you know I've
asked that question to a lot of people
since and most people will say the
middle because it's the hardest the
beginnings they get momentum Billy
describes the three most important turn
to the skier under the last three before
you got in the lift and it's a very very
subtle point and for those of you are
skiers you know that you know that's
when the slope is leveled off is less
challenge most people are very sloppy
then they're taking the muscles off of
they're taking the weight off the
muscles they've been using their bad
form problem that is it on the lift
right up unconsciously you're
internalizing a bad body mechanics as
Billy points out if you your last
returns are precise than what you're
internalizing lift right up is precision
so I carry this on to you know the guys
who I trained in the finance world for
example ending the workday with very
high quality which opens up for one
thing you're internalizing quality
overnight and we're nurturing themes as
well as skills right it's one thing to
learn skills but the higher artists to
learn themes or meta fames that will
ultimately spontaneously opens to them
into the internalization of hundreds of
what I would call local habits
and and so if you're practicing quality
your your deepening the muscle of
quality and you're also focusing the
unconscious mind in an area complexity
which will then tap first thing in the
morning so this is a poor habit
journaling certain post-mortem processes
reflecting on the you know doing ending
your day with a reflection on of the
quality of the work what a core is
complexity that you're that you're
wrestling with um hugely important in
one of those do you do that would you do
that immediately after the end of the
work day per say before bed how would
you time that if someone wanted to try
this themselves i time at the end of the
work day before the problem with doing
these things ended before bed is then
you're sort of consciously going to bed
thinking about these things right that's
why I find you want to release so in a
very core idea is you know when you go
home as best you can unless you're
red-hot inspired release your mind from
the work it's very important to give
your stress and recovery core habit
right you want to be turning it on and
turning it off and keep and teaching
people people to turning it off is a
huge part of teaching them to turn on
much more intensely and so stress in
recovery workouts interval training and
meditation together our beautiful habits
to develop to cultivate the art of
turning it on and turning it off so if
you're undulating your heart rate for
example between 170 170 to 174 and say
144 the practice of lowering your heart
rate over the course of say 45 seconds
is akin to falling asleep
releasing your tension and then as
you're pushing your heart rate back up
you're learning turn-ons you're using a
physical metaphor to train at the art of
turning on incredible intellectual
energy and then trade off more so ever
see every we were talking about one of
my most beautiful memories of him and
you know World Championships before
going into the semi-finals
Broca's bleacher everyone screaming
yelling he's sleeping sleep wake them up
he sort of stumble into the ring you've
never seen a guy more relaxed before
going into a world championship fight um
and then he can turn it off so deeply a
man when he goes in the ring you can't
turn on with anymore intent to he can
and his ability to turn it off is
directly aligned with how intensely you
can turn on so training people to do
this have stress recovery under
throughout their day um and then you
know thematically this ties into again
this internal proactive orientation and
you know building a daily architecture
which is around understanding your
creative process as opposed to reacting
to things feeling guilty that you're not
working really teaching people to tap
into their internal compass mm-hmm so
those are some of the core themes and
habits that I would that I would own
they're not first but I could go on I
could spend three hours talking about
this issue let's do it uh this I will
have part two the the meditation I want
to touch on for a second I mean as you
know I've been taking that very
seriously for particularly particularly
the last six months or so and I received
an email the other day from the the
teacher that I used for a trans dental
meditation and there are many different
types of meditation I'm curious I'm
going to ask you about what how you
format your own meditating in a second
but many different types I have my
issues my likes and dislikes as it
relates to almost all of them but I
received an email with a link to an
article and the title is bridgewater
founder Ray Dalio credits translate all
meditation for his success ahem guys
guys for those who don't know he's the
founder of the world's largest hedge
fund Bridgewater associates they have
100 billion plus under under management
I think and his quote his quote is
meditation more than any other factor
has been the secret to whatever success
I've had that that is a hell of an
endorsement so it's it for me it's been
getting over that resistance to what I
perceived is sort of a wound ooooo type
thing and the ability to view it almost
is just a warm bath for the mind where
I'm taking a mini vacation from my own
brain in a way which may or may not
depending on who you ask be the most
helpful way to look at it but I found
that a very very kind of useful lens
through which to view it but how do you
what what if there is a particular type
of meditation you follow what is it or
how do you personally meditate what do
you think of or not
think of how long do you do it etc yeah
I mean when I was in 1718 I started
studying um very simple contemplative um
and quiescent Buddhist sitting
meditation um or out focus on my breath
um and you know this is when I was a
late teenager and then I I started
getting involved with Tai Chi and I
started setting East Asian philosophy
very deeply and this is where I got
increasingly into moving meditation
which which is the most deep practice or
the practice that I have personally done
most deeply um Tai Chi foreign
meditation type so that the the
meditative form of Tai Chi is sort of
the the essence of the art and then the
fighting application is what I was
competing in and so I spent many years
meditating four or five six hours a day
through tights with Tai Chi um today I
combine my my Tai Chi practice with
sitting meditation again um I mean I
most people when they when they enter
meditation would I would I suggest they
just practice very simple sitting
meditation um following their breath and
it's a practice which doesn't have to be
very complex they can for example just
sit either cross-legged or comfortably
in a chair and have their and follow
their breath and it's very interesting
because they'll notice after one or two
seconds if their mind starts racing off
and usually what happens when you have
really driven guys who are trying to
meditate for the first time and their
mind raises up they get they get all
pissed off it's just like angry
frustration okay because a failing at
meditation and one of the most important
things to do is to embrace the fact that
meditation is about perfection it's
about the return to breath so when you
can find your mind racing you observe
that and you return to your breath
that's a tough emotional hurdle for a
lot guys
and it's very interesting because over
time you know you know the metaphor of
basically the mind is a wild stallion
that over time your attainment and you
don't really learn to still it's racing
it's [ __ ] it's pulling against
anything you put it you think on a line
you put on it but ultimately it the
circles get smaller and smaller and you
learn to observe
of when your mind is getting caught up
in some kind of mental or emotional
addiction more and more quickly and
fluidly and the return under breath
becomes easier and easier and it's very
interesting by the way as a competitor
because I relate to the theme of
channeling emotion or fear whatever is
rising it as a world-class competitor in
very much the same way we might speak
about meditation um you know I I spoke
at a conference on grit recently and it
was very interesting for me because for
the most part when I listen GEOINT
resilience downy RIT yeah which is a
coarse core educational principle in a
lot of charter schools these days hugely
important teaching kids to be resilient
um it's very interesting because what
when I hear people speak about
resilience um from and this is sort of a
removing a little bit of Sighs of
meditation but we'll bring it back the
focus is on for example overcoming
difficulty um suffering learning to to
basically push through what people don't
realize is that world-class performers
what they've done is they've reoriented
their relationship to suffering or that
to the point of resistance they've
learned to embrace it they've learned to
see the beauty in these moments where
there's pains because that's incredible
room for growth and I think that a lot
of what you learn to do in meditation is
observe the addictive way you might be
defining something and if you want to
you can simply alter that definition so
you can change your relationship to pain
or the rain or a huge storm or fear or
anger so for example people from the
outside will use the term fearlessness
right um but if you speak to any great
soldier or SEAL team member or a fighter
or UFC guy they'll tell you mixed
martial arts right a great world-class
fighter
they'll tell you that they feel fear
they just know how to sit with their
fear how to work with it have a channel
so the idea of fearlessness is sort of a
false idea which is imposed from the
outside by a spectator arm and when you
observe world-class performers what
they've learned how to do is harness
fear nerves anxiety bring them in
embrace them have a working relationship
with them and channel them into
intensity meditation is an incredible
forum or vehicle which you can do this
because you learn to observe where you
have addictive relationships and you
realize they're not absolute and you can
actually transform your relationship to
any of these thought patterns thought
constructs cognitive biases or emotional
patterns yeah I was looking up a quote
as you mentioned that because I wanted
to get a right that is one of my
favorite quotes from custom auto who
trained boxers like Floyd Patterson Jose
Torres most famously perhaps Mike Tyson
and he would say the hero and the coward
both feel the same thing but the hero
uses his fear projects it onto his
opponent while the coward runs it's the
same thing fear but it's what you do
with it that matters and I I started
meditating and gave up meditating many
many times because I had the the
response that you mentioned about type-a
personalities where I'd be sitting there
and I thought the objective was to quiet
my mind and I'll come back to that a
second and so when I so when I failed at
quieting my mind because it would be
ticking off the to-do list or being like
ah that [ __ ] said a B and C to me the
other day and I'm just like harp on
these ridiculous things and I'd get then
pissed and then I'd get pissed that I
was getting pissed and I didn't hook to
get up and have a cup of coffee and like
storm out of the house which doesn't
seem that like a productive meditation
session but I I actually started doing
it consistently when I kept it really
short and a friend of mine recommended
this where I would number one be
comfortable so I would I would sit down
but to avoid back pain I would actually
lean against a wall which is very
commonly thought of as a big no-no so
lean against a wall to to keep my back
straight and I listen to one music track
listen to one song every morning the
same song as a cue and I would just pay
attention to my breath and focus on
being an observer of my thoughts but not
trying to control them at all so if all
I did was think about my to-do list the
entire time that's fine as long as I'm
paying attention to my breath and that
non-attachment to an outcome ie
controlling my thoughts was was very
helpful and the the format that I
followed subsequent to that and you know
we can have a longer conversation about
why it finally clicked but the short
answer is accountability I had a teacher
who was going to give me a hard time if
I didn't do my meditating and then
report back I was 20 minutes let's just
say 10 to 20 minutes twice a day and
what I found was by allowing the
thoughts to occur and not judging myself
because let's say I'm thinking about
email or the grocery shopping and to do
or whatever just letting that happen but
getting good at observing it I was able
to then have more emotional awareness
later which would prevent cognitive
biases and bad judgment so what I mean
by that is as a concrete example I'm an
impatient guy I always have been ever
since I was a little literally little
kid like 12 13 years old if I was at the
restaurant with my mom and dad and and
the server didn't come over in pour
water after we'd been gone dry for like
five minutes I just get up and walk into
the kitchen and like grab a pitcher and
walk out and I'm really impatient and I
get angry I mean I get angry about
things that I've you is deliberately
slow and sloppy so for me and and that
anger can be harnessed sometimes and did
really productive aggression but it's
also it wears you down at both ends and
so what I found is after meditating
consistently for even a week or so uh
when that anger would start I was better
at not just become I was better at
observing Tim as a third person right
like - oh look at that like Tim's
getting angry about something really
small it's stupid as opposed to simply
becoming angry and then causing problems
for myself whether it's just internal or
interacting with other people so yeah I
agree with you completely on the
meditation and I love that image of you
as a 12 year old rising into the kitchen
bring up the water it's just a great
metaphor for your life yeah you find
different examples although that is in
the process and you race in there and
you get the water in your place right
thrill I love it uh so let's let's do a
couple of rapid-fire questions that are
that are all tied into this this stuff
but we can just do
short questions with a couple of short
answers so complete the following
statement my favorite time of day is
blank my favorite time of day is holding
my son in my arms after I've done my
I've woken up within a twenty thirty
minute
journaling session I get my son I can I
bring him downstairs and I give him his
bottle of milk and I hold him and I look
him in the eye and I tell them how proud
I am and we talk about what he's
thinking about what he's working on well
he has some milk and I think it's the
most magical part of my day these days
that's in the morning yeah that's that I
wake up I wake up about half an hour
before him I do a big creative burst um
this is Ben what you know he is a parent
your sleep patterns change you know
pretty dramatically but I've I found
this rhythm where I wake up and I do
that person I just love that first
morning energy Tom with him and we have
this deep connection while he's having
his own his milk and ma'am what time do
you wake up talk about thing I usually
wake up around 7:00 7:05 and he's
usually wake up around 7:30 7:35 I'm
endlessly fascinated by morning routines
so this might seem really digging like
I'm digging into the minutiae but when
you wake up it sounded like you wake up
and you have 30 minutes to journal
before bringing your son downstairs do
you brush your teeth drink a cup of
coffee any of that before you journal or
do you just roll out of bed walk into
the office and sit down to write my
routine is that I roll out of bed I
brush my teeth I go downstairs and I sit
down with my journal and I start writing
and I immediately apply myself to to a
reflection that I've sort of targeted my
mind at in the M in the evening or late
afternoon before and then I when after I
just let it rip I have a big creative
search um and then once I hear my son I
go get him and then then I have my
breakfast um usually a Belote meal um
while he has is you know after he has
his notes in the night I have a cup of
coffee about half an hour after that
cool
related to you strike me as a happy guy
obviously we all have our challenges Hey
then again I like the place I'm getting
remodeled at the moment ah which I want
I don't ever I won't go into diatribe at
the moment I'm very excited about it but
it's my 12 year old Tim wanting to go
get the water pitcher that's not been
very helpful right now
ah the what are three things could be
two three things you believe you need in
order to be happy and that could be for
you it could be for people in general
I'm just curious
uh what how you would think of that
question or answer that question if you
want the great things about you and I
being dear friends and having the
conversations is that you tend to be
very good at thinking in bullets and
list of three things initially my friend
but I can tell you the essence of how I
relate that question yeah so I'm not
going to give you the free three bullet
answer because I just that's just not
how this brain operates I I mean I I've
built a lifestyle around being true to
myself uh uh largely maybe a big reason
is because of you know my mom used to
always tell me as a kid to follow my
heart follow my dreams
um I never made decisions for money or
for external things um I always trusted
if I was true to myself these things
would follow and so you know my
professional life my foundation my
school I only work with people who I
feel are ethically aligned who have a
good energy who I feel really good about
intuitively um I keep empty space in my
life um I rarely have more than one or
two meetings a day my life is about
quality not quantity and to add depth
and not breath um my business is based
on doing very very deep and very a
excellent work with just a handful of
people and so I really like to cultivate
quality as a way of life and I believe
that when you're not cultivating quality
you're essentially cultivating
sloppiness and so right you know the
idea of building the musculature of
quality and being like a heat-seeking
missile Foreman I take great pleasure in
observing the beauty of the little
moments in life
um and so for me my lifestyle is based
on you know I'm working out everyday I
just focused on structure and it will
allow for my creative process to be rich
I'm present with my son I have my office
at home I'm with him in the morning I'm
with him seeing throughout the day I'm
with him it was bass and freedom his
story nighttime with him I've limited
almost all travel that takes me away um
from from my boy going to a conference
weekend I'm taking my wife and my baby
are coming with me
um and I really build a life around
being true and I don't build it around
anything material and and that's really
the essence of how I personally relate
to this question of course there's
different solutions for everybody but um
that's works for me this is something
that that is being true to oneself I
think that most people struggle with
right I think it's a I think it's a goal
that most people have at least in the
abstract but I'd love to dig into some
concrete details of that and perhaps you
could share an example of something you
changed like maybe where you got
slightly off the path and made a
correction to be true to yourself and
what that looked like
uh yeah well I mean for me a very clear
example is is my public life so I I was
a young kid fell in love with Jess um
when I was I won my first national
championship when I was late eight early
nine when I was eleven a book came out
searching for I Fisher um and then when
I was fifteen
movie came out about my life based on
the same book that my dad initially
wrote and so I was really thrust into
the spotlight and so I you know without
me wanting to I was just you know a
young passionate artist I loved playing
chess and competing in chess I was put
out there and I had paparazzi following
me everywhere I was um you know I was
really living in in the spotlight in a
way I wasn't necessarily emotionally
prepared for and I felt in my teens how
that challenged my love for this art
because my love for it was so pure
initially um and and in that tension you
know that that fight that sight to stay
true to my art um
taught me some very deep lessons and
then I in don't
after I finished high school I took off
and I left the country largely to study
chess very deeply undistracted from
publicity I moved to Eastern Europe um
my girlfriend at the time was from
Slovenia no one knew me out there and it
was a beautiful life I just left the
public world and since then I you know
when I came back I've had these periods
where I've been exposed to publicity and
I've been Experian
away from it and and I think this is a
very clean example for us I mean other
than you very few people drag me out oh
my god throw throw a net over the bear
and drag him out of the kick you have a
way of doing that to me um but but in a
beautiful way and I mean I found that
the privacy of my life um not doing
things not getting caught up in in you
know the swirl of Fame or seeking
external adulation is a very important
thing for me personally and what
everyone's different but but for me I
mean I amazes maybe I have a little bit
of a um and over sensitivity to this
because of my my youth because I was out
there so intensely as a young as a young
guy and I think it really challenged my
love for the game um this is an example
of of the kind of decision that I'll
make I mean I think it's very important
for me to to live the vast majority of
my life privately I don't do very much
that will allow me to be recognized in
the street and live my life as a
celebrity because I've gone down that
path and I I love my privacy yeah um and
I also have built you know a career
around my business is working with
people who are similar who are not
seeking the limelight who are not out
there on television every day who world
class but are no one around them other
than people you know very close have any
idea that they have been so incredibly
successful from the monetary way they
try to raise their kids um not to be
spoiled um the kids are gritty kids that
they're you know great philanthropists
um really good people and I love I'm
very drawn to people who have been
enormous to successful um but don't get
caught up in the external crap that
comes with success
um and a real you know who were living
their life tapped into the love and
that's how I try to live what uh what
are some of you are what are the books
let's just stick with books for a second
that you've either most gifted to other
people or most recommended to other
people because if there are many people
listening to this probably who won't
necessarily have the opportunity to
interact with the types of high-level
folks that that you and I are are so
fortunate to have the chance to interact
with but they can do that visa the books
worth narratives documentary by etc what
what are some books that have had a
formative impact on you I mean so if we
go back to when I was seventeen eighteen
Jack Kerouac and a huge impact in my
life on the road Dahmer bums this is
mister Siew these are the you know his
books were initially kind of tapped me
into the idea that life could be
ecstatically beautiful and I moved into
studying um Taoism so Lao Tzu on the
dashing hugely just unbelievably deep
but of course the translation of that
book that you read will be formative and
I my favorite translations the GF who
Fang and Jane English translation of the
dashing zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance I think one of the most
important books ever written by Robert
person who has become a very dear friend
over the years he when my when the owner
of London came out my publisher asked me
who would you love to read this book and
I said well the one person that really
want to read that book is um Robert
Percy and but he to me that was just you
know he lived like a deeply secluded
life um but they somehow managed to get
him a copy the book he got in a big
bushel from his publisher any reddit nee
contacted me and wrote I mean I was so
honored that he that he was moved by it
and he a knight and over the years it
developed really interesting dialogue um
that his only our motorcycle maintenance
is one I think one of the most important
books in the world the focus on quality
dynamic quality I'm finding art in
learning to find art in anything really
deeply brilliant um philosophical book
um Shantaram one of the most beautiful
novels I found I never read gravity
Roberts also someone I've gotten to know
very well um just a ecstatically
beautiful beautiful book and you know of
course I'm also a lover of fiction I
mean Hemingway has been he's probably
the most important writer of my life um
and it's everything in his effort any
particular novel stand out for you it is
oh I I mean I think that for Whom the
Bell Tolls just exquisite novel green
hills of Africa amazing um his short
stories are utterly magnificent um the
green hills of Africa is one of the most
is one of the most underrated books that
he's written
um his complete collection of short
stories I mean there's one magnificent
gem at to the next um of course old men
the sea is everyone takes about an
e-book I guess if I had to have a
favorite it would be it would be for
Whom the Bell Tolls for Whom the Bell
Tolls yeah for those people listening
you also want insight into his writing
style a moveable feast is a magnificent
book again yeah also Ronettes where I
mean really speaks to his writing
process
yeah hash-table so fascinating it is a
great book by the way Tim when I think I
think you've read um which is I I think
it's Hemingway on writing yeah I read
this book I did read it yet I also read
that yeah ah I mean if you want to
always get to know heavyweights - it's
just a fantastic compilation of all
Hemingway's writing in letters in his
books and his articles everywhere um put
together thematically basically
Hemingway on the writing process I think
it's one of the most important little
collections of um on creativity that
I've ever run into
absolutely brilliant plan right and it's
really short I remember I read it on
down I read it on Kindle on a short
flight that I had and just like jammed
right through the whole thing the one of
the recommendations was a a trite trunk
edit sober and I realized that write
drunk edit sober does not translate to
podcasts very well the last podcast that
I did with
buddy Kevin Rose laughs if you record
drunk and try to edit sober it doesn't
really actually work the same way man
what uh Bulls do a couple more questions
because this has been fun the but if you
had to run out of your house and just
take a handful of things with you
obviously your family is safe so that
that's accounted for uh what would you
take
and why in what kind of situation uh in
a very dangerous situation not you don't
have to fend for yourself with with
weaponry or create fire with flint or
anything like that there's there's a
fire in your house you just have to get
out to the street and then you're in
obviously sort things out later but
assuming your family is safe what would
you what would you take with you just
what you can carry basically that's a
really great question I actually had
that experience years ago when I was
playing chess and speaks of how crazy I
was I was um there was a I was studying
chess with this brilliant Russian
Grandmaster nemuri reserve I actually
wrote about my book and there was a
fifth floor walk-up there's a old
one-bedroom I had my my first apartment
and um and there was sudden we were deep
deep into chess study and there was a
huge fire and I looked at there were
like five fire engines and dudes
screaming at us and we had it did go out
the fire escape and I ended up going
back in and grabbing my computer with
all my chess and else it was just a
random thing to do so on
speaks I had different overcome um yeah
and then ended up being weird in seconds
from being updraft and blowing the whole
building on um yeah so I wouldn't do
that no man I think I'm I honestly when
you ask me a question out I think that
my family was safe I have nothing
material that I would um that I would
grab that's great that's that's a it's a
very stoic response in the most positive
way all right man I'm gonna ask you one
more actually and I'll give you a choice
two questions let's do that so the the
first option is what did you want to be
when you grew up so when you're a kid
and what now how would you answer the
question
what do you want to be when you grow up
that's that's question of one question
number two is if you had a committee of
three people living or dead to help you
make decisions who would you choose and
why either he's a great questions man
thanks by the way I'm borrowing
liberally from like every good
interviewer I've ever come in contact
all right but so it goes can we answer
them both you might answer one of them
uh uh you can answer those two very
different questions I mean this is tough
man yeah I need to think if they I'm
just trying to be respectful of your
time but if you have time and you have
some thoughts on both let's let's let's
go for it when I grew up I wanted to be
when I was when I was a kid I wanted to
be a professional baseball player I just
love I love them so there's something
about sport um so I I think that there
was a I mean and I spent a lot of my
life as a competitor from age basically
six until you know 35 I was basically a
professional competitor in that field um
today you know but my mom always said to
me that she felt like that was a phase
and that I was a healer I was holding
her language and a lot of what I do
today is try to figure out how to help
people will express themselves in as
pure way as possible artistically in a
way to get some joy I mean I think that
my plan is sometime in the next four or
five years I'm 37 now I'm thinking about
it when I'm 40 41 um
because I'd be three four years now I'm
getting cold just to turn my mind to
everything taking everything I've been
doing these different laboratories and
apply it to a world changing education
initiative yeah um helping children in a
just fulfill themselves in a very deep
way I think is a central calling which
I'm that's that's I'm not going to days
my end game but that's that's the next
um major chapter I think of my life that
I'm building towards um running my
foundation for for many years now and we
do beautiful work but I have an allergy
to scaling if it's going to dilute
quality in any way and
so I've been sort of building up the
found eight like that the ground work to
ultimately be able to to do something
hugely important to education so I think
that's going to be the core of how I
would I would own I'm building towards
that in a few years in terms of the
committee of three people just just to
interject for a second that's that's
also I think my calling and of course
we've spoken at length about this so if
you need a co-conspirator count me in
for that one certain yeah dude let's
plan on this let's say four or five we
have to figure out what it's going to be
maybe four or five years we'll team up
and we'll take the world by storm
nice paper sounds like a plan man oh I
love it just sort of as taps that it
that movement away from self minute as a
competitor you're constantly you're
fighting in many ways you're you know
you're there's something about the focus
inward on oneself and I becoming a
parent I have definitely felt this
movement um away from that I mean my son
is just my love for him just so
transcends anything I ever I ever felt
before it's been really really important
to experience when you become a dad man
then we're gonna have some fun
I can't wait forward to your sleepless
nights oh man yeah you're gonna you're
going to see a battle-weary Timbo I got
I need to I need to work on my
polyphasic sleep bye so yeah this is a
committee of three people what are your
thoughts well one person who who would
be on that committee as someone who um I
had know very very deep friend of mine
who happens to be in the in the finance
world um isn't it Dave I can't speak
about his last name is but just a deeply
meditative spirit great wisdom um
as insightful human being as I've ever
known in my life and I think that he
would definitely be on him on that list
um I mean can we go can we go into can I
say outrageous judges like like Gandhi
yeah go go yeah yeah I mean it I think
about a
Gandhi Lao Tzu the Buddha I mean my god
what would it what a.m. but if you use a
certain yeah I don't know man I don't
know if I can answer this question very
intelligently hue placate that's it
that's a perfect way to end yeah I don't
know and Tim of course you man I mean
you give me you give me so much crap in
life that have to call you because you'd
be the one just to just keep me you
definitely be one to slice through all
the nonsense yet and my mom that's the
most important one my mom yeah she has
given me the most um deep advice in my
life I mean my mom is the one person who
has really embraced these crazy
decisions that I've made when I have
left arts when I was at the tops of
their field of those fields and because
of some strange calling her head inside
I think um no I'm not to be the top of
any list like that she's my hero I'm the
greatest person if your normal life
awesome is well this is uh this has been
a lot of fun obviously we're gonna have
a lot more conversations is there
anything you want to any parting
thoughts advice suggestions anything
like that the diet you'd like to impart
if not we can we can we can call it a
day but the mic is yours if you have
anything that you'd like to add
no I love this has been a really
interesting that I am I guess if I if
I'm going to close with a thought it
would be that you know when I when a one
thing that I've been doing in the last
year's absence writing the owner mode of
learning is I've been exposed some of
the most brilliant thinkers in these
different fields and I've studied the
patterns behind them and I've studied
the people who study them and one of the
things we have to be wary of in life is
studying the the people who study the
artists as opposed to the artist himself
arm person who the author of them they
are the most psycho man and so that I
mentioned he uses this great term the
Philosopher's and the Philosopher's
gist's right most of all just the ones
who are busy philosophizing about the
Philosopher's is going to do in
philosophy and the vast majority of
philosophers today actually are just
lost apologist similarly is you know you
know I've discussed there's the writers
and there's a literary critic
there's the artist in the art critic and
I think that we have to be very careful
when we when we study excellence and
we're thinking about our own path to
excellence um that we're studying that
they were tuning into the direct
experience that people have actually
been there as opposed to the armchair
professors who are talking about it
right um because you know if we spend
our life in the trenches and we spend
our life studying that last like 0.1% of
learning process what we see is that
that that final passage to excellence is
really about navigating that razor's
edge where you have to be willing to go
right up against a potential enormous
blunder and you get to improvise for
example trust your intuition and moments
where all the objective mathematical
faculties you've developed to telling
you something else but your intuition is
operating at a higher level um you have
to really be willing to go up to the
like the brink of disaster um to succeed
in moments where for example fighting in
the finals of a world championship or in
the very last seconds of a Super Bowl or
an NBA Finals um and in navigating these
things the armature professors will
often have the exact opposite of good
advice right and so so what I would say
is is for one thing you know listen
deeply internally to the core of your
being and build your game plan from
there trust your gut and then build a
lifestyle um around listening to that
and cultivate the love and that's the
other thing I'd say is it whether you're
talking about the beginning of the
learning process or that were the very
you know the very final surge or surges
it's about the love we think about
parenting cultivating resilience cause
of any excellence cultivating creativity
with the armchair professors all forget
about is the love um and that's what I
see consistently with people who have
found the most pleasure the most
happiness um and created the greatest
art is that they have a profound passion
for what they do not only the big
moments but the little moments but the
moments that others would call pain they
learn to love practice they learn to
love the point of resistance um don't
forget about the love I guess that's
what I'd like to say
that's it that's a beautiful way to end
this man well Josh uh I'm sure we will
be talking next time we'll have some
wine and a good book and yeah I hope
everybody checks out
obviously the art of learning and really
keeps an eye on on what you have coming
when you decide to push stuff out of the
cave so thanks for watching I had George
all right buddy I will talk to you soon
if you want more of the Tim Farriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes or go to for our blog comm fo u
Rho er Bao Zhi , where you'll find an
award-winning vlog tons of audio and
video interview stories with people like
Warren Buffett and Mike Shinoda from
Lincoln Park the books plus much much
more follow him on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or Riss or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening
you